[Applause]
miss brian you all have some prime real
estate here at 30 we bring we do we do
we're so lucky i mean this is only one
of two rooftops we have two oh my god we
have two we'll get your cute cell phone
over here show me the place
how long did this renovation take
they did everything and there is more in
23 days what that more includes a
merchandise store featuring caroline's
clothing line and it's also available to
fans online we've got best bad influence
here how did that come about like
especially the phrase back in the day
somebody made a comment that i was a bad
influence and i was a really good kid i
wasn't and it it hurt me to the court
and so i walked off thinking well if i'm
a bad influence then i'm the best bad
influence she'll ever have
so i'm getting a little moon crew vibe
up in here well there's obviously this
huge i guess that's a marlin
um you know up there and you know
bringing in some fish and deer heads and
pictures of him holding fish so this
definitely is the man cave vibe yeah
baby you can't crash my party anytime
you and luke have been having a whole
lot of fun for the last 23 years is that
right we met 1998.
i can't believe it
what is luke like behind the scenes he
is the biggest nut job he was up this
morning
drinking too much coffee aggravating me
but he's just how he acts on stage is
really how he is at home
your love of pranking one another is
exceptional well that started in college
too yes do you recall the first prank
y'all pulled on one another the first
prank luke actually put vaseline under
my car door handles
and it was disgusting but i got him back
i actually went to he lived in a
fraternity house
and we broke into his room i had friends
hoist me up and i put a can of tuna
in his air vents
okay so can we talk about the prank that
you recently pulled on american idol i
dressed up as an annoying stage hand it
turned out great it was fun when i put
this card
guys hold on one second who was that
thank you
that is enough
chill
hey hey
oh my god
[Music]
has he gotten you back not yet oh but
you know
when you leave
it's coming well
i think we deserve a little beverage
let's do it cheers thank you so much for
having us thank you
[Music]
you